cuerpos entre el lodo es la imagen de la
desolación en República democrática del
Congo luego de que las lluvias
torrenciales arrasaran con buena parte
del territorio calejo en la provincia de
kibú del Sur La docente en otro hospital
tenemos 56 pacientes que están siendo
atendidos pero hay que decir que hay
dificultades con su atención no hay
suficientes medicamentos e insumos
médicos como guantes jeringas con presas
tonos
las inundaciones
riadas y los deslizamientos de tierra
dejan casi dos centenares de Muertos las
autoridades esperan que sean más a
medida que avanzan las labores de
búsqueda y rescate
[Aplausos]
perdí a mi esposo y ahora me quedo con
cinco hijos
perdí a mi esposa y a 16 de mis hijos
todo se ha ido ahora estoy solo en mi
casa pensé que este tipo de desastres
naturales son frecuentes por el tipo de
suelo vulnerable a la erosión la región
congoleña no había sido azotada por
lluvias de esta magnitud desde 2014 que
dejaron más de un centenar de
desaparecidos ahora piden ayuda
humanitaria para paliar la catástrofe me
explicó es importante que alertemos a
las autoridades a nivel del gobierno
nacional y del gobierno provincial para
que nos ayuden porque la gente que vive
aquí no tiene donde vivir ni que comer
la gente está durmiendo a la intemperie
hay escuelas que están arrasadas
pocos días antes la vecina Ruanda
también fue golpeada por las intensas
lluvias y las inundaciones que dejaron
más de 5000 viviendas arrasadas y 130
fallecidos